[Musique]
soucieux de renforcer l'accès des
réunionnés au service publics tout en
facilitant leur prise en charge le
département de La Réunion a lancé en
2022 les forums territorialisés de
l'action sociale et de l'insertion
depuis plusieurs forums ont été
organisés dans chaque microrégion pour
aller à la rencontre des publics isolés
ce mardi 28 novembre c'est au Champ de
Foire de brapanon que les partenaires
publics et associatifs ont installé leur
stand pour la deuxè édition du Forum sur
le bassin est l'objectif c'est de
rassembler d'abord le le département et
de présenter le panel de dispositifs que
met en place le département il y a la
caravane d'accès au droit il y a les
différents dispositif de l'insertion
dans le dispositif R+ c'est des exemples
que je peux vous donner mais il y en a
plein c'est de présenter les différents
partenaires aussi qui sont à nos côtés
certains partenaires associatifs qui
sont financés par le Département
certains CCS qui se sont associés à nous
mais aussi la Mission Locale l'objectif
c'est de s'unir pour mieux informer et
pour mieux accompagner la mission locale
œuvre dans tous les domaines aussi bien
pour vous aider à accéder à un emploi à
une formation pour définir avec vous
votre projet professionnel pour vous
aider dans le dans les problématiques de
logement ou d'hébergement si vous avez
des problématiques de santé on peut vous
apporter des informations vous orienter
vers des services qui vont vous aider
notamment pour l'écoute psychologique le
public du bassin est pouvait également y
découvrir des conseils en nutrition une
démonstration de
Taishi mais aussi des solutions pour
faire des économies aujourd'hui nous on
a le même combat qui est la souveraineté
alimentaire et la transition écologique
solidaire et énergétique donc l'idée
c'est avec le recyclage grâce à la
semaine européenne de réduction de
déchets c'est d'habituer un petit peu le
créole avec des moyens très simples de
recyclage de faire son petit jardin et
en même temps ser sur le gâteau on leur
offre des petits plans de piment pour
pouvoir faire leur jardin chez eux donc
il y a pas des petites économies il y a
que de bonnes actions de grandes actions
le forum territorialisé de l'action
sociale et de l'insertion poursuit son
tour de lîle rendez-vous le mercredi 6
décembre prochain de 8h30 à 13h au
gymnase du lycée Victor chelcher à
[Musique]
Saint-Louis